hey everybody welcome back to kawali zoo
it's already time for episode 31 and
today i am joined by
rudy and mike how are you guys doing
doing all right still live yeah that's
very good we had a wildfire about 10
miles from our house but we're good
we're okay oh man
oh to be honest the way that this
episode came together
is what is happening
yes look we're just gonna ignore
whatever's happening there actually no
we're gonna head into time we're just
ignoring the black box
what the hell the black you mean that
takes up like 80 of the screen and mike
and i can't see anything
i mean i was thinking we're just gonna
have to cut this out and start a new but
on the other hand this is just kind of
an explanation of what has been going on
with my computer and why this episode
has come
so late so i think we might like three
weeks later something like that yeah
yes it's it's also to blame on me you
know
yeah not only blaming himself that's
true what happened again exactly
in short you know i'm also working from
home and i'm working with microsoft
teams and the problem microsoft teams
has is
you can't set the microphone to a
constant value it has an automatic voice
detection which you can't disable
and i didn't notice it was still running
in the background when we tried to
record on a discord and so it always
overrode
my discord settings and so i was always
cut off and then we thought sylves
computer is slowly dying because he had
the cutoff issues as well someday
which it is and we didn't really think
about it it could be me and
i just only noticed until very much
later when i tried to call someone else
and he was saying like hey you also have
like cutouts and was like what the [ __ ]
and yeah that was teams then so guys
never use teams when you do anything
just
kill it fair enough to switch the
discord honestly
yeah so here we are in kuala lumpur yeah
i was about to say let's actually start
a quick tour
um this episode is kind of interesting
because i think
time wise it's the one that i spent most
hours on
i spent a lot of time even while this
was delayed just tinkering away at this
uh without recording because um it's
it's untime lapseable honestly um
it's mostly well without spoiling too
much it's just fixing up the old hotel
building because what went wrong here
essentially is i think i
i built this building without the
intention of ever making
you know full detailed interiors which
was a horrible idea for a bunch of
different
reasons um but shortly after of course
uh even came with the amazing sweat
suites which are
absolutely beautiful and i was just like
great
now my hotel just looks horrible and it
doesn't have an interior that fits and
you know the whole file is just a mess
um
so i've spent the past couple weeks just
replacing every single wall
and window and changing the dimensions
of this building everything slightly to
make sure that hotel rooms could fit
into
it and i'm so sorry so it's totally
fine but turns out i think it's more
challenging to take an existing like
shell of a building and give it an
interior than it is to just make a
building from the start with an interior
so i
really should have just done that in the
first place
oh yeah it is i'm excited because okay
so you
basically retrofitted this building
because i'm looking at i'm like oh this
looks like the
one that we ended on but no it's it's
retrofitted with
space for interiors now yeah and also
you see a couple of changes on the
balconies i guess
yeah yeah there are a few changes here
and there also there are some new lights
on the outside um slightly different um
scenery obviously it says uh silver
suites at the front here now the uh
the sort of entrance and um there's just
some some small
changes to it the the white section
between the tower
and the apartment sections which used to
be just
white same stucco walls it's now bamboo
to try and
you know separate the tower a little bit
more from the rest of the building could
be
improved a little bit maybe set back a
bit but um
yeah yeah exactly um but yeah let's just
walk into it i also made a few changes
here on the plaza there's actually a
fence now
around here that prevents people from
jumping into the water because it was
really just a white ledge here
okay we can also just put some piranhas
in when we get them so they will all
jump in oh that would be great honestly
um although i think this this pool
doesn't really this isn't really
conducive to any light at all
there are actually some like swimming
pool lights on the the bottom of this as
well now so at night you'll be able to
see underwater oh good i just recently
tested that this engine has a really
good display of underwater lighting when
oh yeah it's really unfortunate that it
doesn't really pay out at daytime but at
nighttime it looks really
really sweet yeah it's great um so yeah
here we walk
up to the silk suites it's quite simple
the idea of this is that in the end it
will be expanded into this area where
there will be a restaurant and a proper
lobby section
and all that but this would be a direct
way for the people who live
in the well who have a room in the hotel
hopefully they don't actually live there
to just directly go to their rooms um go
up the elevator or the stairs
uh without having to go through all of
the restaurant section that's awesome
yeah that's something i've noticed a lot
with like tropical areas that you end up
having these tower complexes
and as long as you've got like the uh
the little key card you can just go
directly into your tower complex without
having to go back through
um like the the hotel main lobby or
anything like that yeah exactly
that's a super good call though i didn't
include any little key card swipers
next time i'm definitely going to add
those in the meantime okay so now that
sets the bar for the detailer
yes i'm excited um so yeah let's just
get into the the self suites and see
what it's like
it's quite simple on the inside here um
but i tried to make the style a little
bit
uh fitting with this wet suites as well
nice so either you just take the
elevator or you just take the stairs up
i have to say there are some unfinished
rooms where i couldn't really figure out
what to do with them exactly there's one
transition
over here which could connect to the
other wing
of the building and then there's another
room here and
i'm honestly thinking these could be
conference rooms as well with a screen
and tables and things like this um
because this won't be used for
a restaurant or lobbies or anything like
that i mean if we could put our own
billboards on
we could use some cool screens of some
kuali workshops in the future that'd be
awesome
oh that's a really cool idea yeah yeah
so
we can actually actually put some some
of the habitat thingies in as like a
little reference here that would be cool
right yeah it's a very i love it i love
the freaking
lights on the elevators yeah i noticed
that uh
this wet suites also had like hanging
light fixtures in some ways i was like
all right we have to do something
similar but different
for this to try and go for some sort of
you know fitting yeah mike is right like
the elevator lights indicating it's on
the third floor
um so yeah unfortunately we don't have a
functional elevator in this game so i
guess we're just gonna
take the stairs up uh to where we wanna
be
um and then we just have i think
how many floors well i know this this
building has a bunch of different floors
but
um they're basically all these floors i
think i made yeah
two different hotel rooms and um
yeah the bottom floors are all the same
room and then the top floor are actually
single
rooms as well oh cool so you access the
rooms from the outer
balcony yeah exactly the challenge with
this building was that it's a little bit
too narrow
to actually add a hallway in the middle
of the building and rooms on either side
so so for the for the dimensions of this
building i think this was the
the way that worked out best and i think
it kind of gives it sort of a motel
feeling
in my imagination this could also be
just the cheaper hotel
of the resorts because the the wet
suites are very fancy
and you know they don't have as many
places whereas this is a much
you know larger building with more
compartmentalized rooms that are
a bit smaller simpler and uh just a
larger context
i think i mean this is where most of us
would be staying instead of this
yes definitely i mean to be fair the
random investor comes around to build
quality and
pay us the money for the concept
[Laughter]
no to be fair honestly in my my history
of going to zoos and theme parks i
always just stay at a very cheap place
nearby
and walk to the to the site obviously
that's sir
i think he also is good by now because
no one uses e-schoolers anymore so you
will definitely find one
oh really nobody uses those anymore in
germany nobody
it's like they're lying around
everywhere like whatever oh yeah
i always take note of like which ones
you can find on the street because i
once had a lecture about those things
and the whole economy behind it it's
really interesting to see like the
different companies always competing in
different cities and
whenever i visit a new city i'm just
like all right so these are the the the
bike sharing
uh companies these are the scooter
companies interesting
but um sorry i'm getting way off travel
oh you guys talk about travel that's
hotel room forget about everything
that's happening in the onset world
right now right
um 101 because that's a cool number i
just wanted to go into 101. um so
quite simple we just have a little place
to drop your coats here
uh a bathroom with a door that we can't
see through this
way dang you did this and a shower and
everything
oh i love it that's another level
little like a heater thing this is this
is honestly oh yeah a towel rack heater
or something like that
yeah i figured this would really work as
a bathroom heater like just one piece
there we go
the rest of the room is uh it's very
simple just a double bed
large bed little barrels on the side and
uh
a small desk and a tv on the other
damn side looks so believable this is
really nice
thank you guys so uh it's all quite
simple honestly just a bunch of wooden
beams and stucco but really the
challenge was trying to
um the way that i did this was honestly
quite weird
uh i just took the the profile of the
space that we have here and made it a
separate building which is all of the
interiors
um so so the way like for instance i
could i could grab this
and if i start to uh move it around here
um you could see that like the interior
all goes away and the uh
the empty room space is still left
but it worked as a decent way to you
know copy
just make one room and then copy it into
all the different spaces of the building
oh absolutely especially if you didn't
plan on making the exterior
as part of your interior i mean this is
this is a good way to do it
exactly looking so cool i love the light
switches the little ones next to the bed
like it's always the one who gets the
light switch to turn it off
this is always the one in the room who
has the light switch for only that lamp
and the other one has that for the whole
room
when you have that for the whole room
and clicking the wrong one you are
basically
the room light switch is at the door for
this room though so
at the bed you really only just have the
light switches for uh here on the side
but maybe they could be yeah for the
reading lights yeah i know who would we
may
walk in a lot at night it'll be me then
turn on the light turn off the light i
know cool for some reason i'm an adult
now but whenever i go to bed i still
first turn on the reading light and then
i turn off the big
turn off so yeah turn on the reading
light and then turn off the big light
then get into the bed and then turn off
the little reading line i'm just like
alright i didn't have to walk through my
room in the dark
great yeah you're just trying to keep
yourself from stubbing your toe on
something
yes of course i'm keeping my my toes
safe
that's that's the that's the reason
we'll go with it i mean we all played
with lego we all know what it means to
keep the toys
oh my gosh oh yes well and i have like
a wired headphones so i trip over that
wire and i'm going through the window
oh god oh yeah to be fair i still have
wired headphones too i just
kind of like the safety and having
everything analog as well
but basically i just destroyed one
lately when i was playing a racing game
i didn't notice that it was kind of
caught in the
in the steering wheel and i made a hefty
correction while rising and i just
completely ripped it out of
out of the connection it just happened
yep cool well this is really really well
done
my goodness so yeah that's uh that's our
hotel room
i uh i actually still have to fix if i
fixed up every
sea if i fixed up everything in the
staircase because maybe there's still
some
some some glitchy parts there but if all
is well
let's just head up to the the top floor
and
um see what we can do there uh
sorry guys it's gonna take a while i'm
doing it all by hand instead of just
jumping out of touch it's cam but i want
to make sure they actually
get there in a legit way i was about to
say that's like no real stack is right
i mean if you would have fit that in and
then put some i don't know vending
machines in the rooms
hidden in there you know i want to get
people to actually use it
yeah that would be nice to actually make
that functional
uh but yeah this is the top floor and as
you can notice it's a little bit smaller
um but if we go into one of the rooms
here we have just a
slightly smaller situation going on i
notice there's a roof piece which i'm
gonna have to
remove because there's some z fighting
um
but yeah that is wait do all the rooms
have that wow the higher you go the
worse the room gets
okay we will fix the z finding on that
one
but uh yeah that aside it's it's the
bathroom is actually pretty much the
same
it's just a little bit stronger and you
just have a single bed in here because
it's
hard to fit in anything else um but yeah
that's the treetop cabin for the
[Music]
i mean to add a little bit of a story to
it if we're talking about like uh
conference rooms in the ground
that makes even sense to have these
single apartments on top because mostly
that's what you have for like travelling
people you know getting to conferences
you would have like journalists they
mostly come on their own
yeah totally if they don't have a secret
relationship at work or whatnot
[Laughter]
or they just get a luxurious two-person
room anyway even though they're alone
but um i mean it's just it's just six
one-person rooms so
you never know can always use them
how many rooms are on each level uh so
there's six rooms
on each level and there are five levels
in total so it's 30 rooms
cool that's that's the decent number
well you could blow out the wall to the
right and make it a double uh double
suite oh that's a very good point hmm
i know you don't want to do it
i know i know i actually sounded very
sarcastic there but i was
um yeah i'm very very done with
moving walls and stuff around in this
building and trying to get things to
work i am
absolutely killing my past self for the
dimensions of this building but i think
at the end of the day it it worked out
into something that's
at least realistic enough for uh for the
purpose
it looks really cool so yeah like it's
it's so great that from the outside you
don't really see a difference but then
it really makes a huge difference
from from what the building is i totally
also must add
to the fact that also i saw that with
its sweat suites as well
you kind of get a better understanding
of the dimensions you know when you have
all the interior done
it is kind of obvious that you have to
do it the right size you know
exactly so that makes the building by
natural looking a lot more realistic
because you have to
you know stick to the sizes required
yeah totally i find that really cool
yeah i think you get much more realistic
composition and just
overall shape of a building if you try
to you know think of how the the
interior could look and how different
rooms would work for sure
you find very often for instance people
who place chimneys on top of buildings
where
somewhere below that that chimney
there's a window
and that's like one of those issues that
you'd never get into that unrealistic
situation if you try to work out the
interior space as well
that's right but in planet coaster
though it was never an issue because we
used gymnasts for everything
that's true that's right oh god
well that's awesome i mean what is your
grand plan in this kind of area
um so my grand plan i still have
somewhat of a grand plan ideally
um this building will connect to this
lower section which is where the
restaurant will be
because logically i just didn't see a
good way to to fit a lower
section into this building and i think
this this makes more sense as a layout
um and then on this side could maybe be
a swimming pool
that was my ultimate to be honest we'll
see if that actually works
um but i thought we're cool but that's
what i was thinking about i think if i
if i may give you a suggestion because
we do have that swimming pool in the
sweat suites with which is more like an
infinity
relaxed chill pool yeah i think it would
be cool to have like a little
reminiscence of
of kuali you know that this might be a
little bit more also for kids like
pool area i think that would be cool
yeah no i totally agree i was thinking
of
a much you know more shoddy looking pool
uh more cheap looking maybe a
bit sketchy you know um but with some
water slides and stuff
i i think that would be you know the
kind of place that this is
yeah curves are for chumps totally
but actually there are some fun some fun
things to talk about speaking of curves
these
this is my like working file away from
kuali zoo
um because my computer absolutely can't
handle it but i still have the circles
lying about from when i was making this
this water
element with the semicircles and here is
actually the the hotel rooms
as they are without the nice exterior
walls so that's kind of funny just
looking
you know what the layout of these things
is right
i was totally reminded of the same uh
there's also something interesting in
this fire which i guess deserves some
showing off it's just this random old
idea for
for the building which was like a modern
version of the hotel that never
ended up making it through and i'm very
glad because i
i would have no idea how to make hotel
rooms with this thing because it's like
all curvy
shapes are way harder to work with so
guys
expect that the next delay is like five
weeks then because we will switch this
in
i mean it's too cool to not use
okay please take that back it's it's not
cool enough to be worth the hassle of
making it usable i think
well i don't know if it necessarily
needs to be usable it just needs to be
kind of like that background scenery
that that you're looking for with a
tower complex that's a very fair point
there's still a parking lot to work on
as well
uh we're doing that too
it would be cool to try it oh lord
maybe that could be somewhere around
there i guess i have to promise to not
start anything new next episode
oh yeah i mean that's that's kuwali at
this point is really just
we did all of the fun stuff and all of
the stuff that you can just quickly you
know build something cool and show it
off and be like yeah that's so cool but
now
i mean i wouldn't agree on quickly
though okay
yeah i know that i've got one one new
area that i want to do
and then i've got to clean up all my
other areas and then i think
that's you know i don't know what else
we can do i would imagine like a
public transport hub or are we doing
like a
full-on parking garage or because
there's not a whole lot of room that
we've left oh i
i think yeah i think either way even if
if there's coming something bigger
updatey in in the future
it also wouldn't be fit in here like we
just don't have the space to
go i think from the concept that the zoo
is done
and you just have to to wrap it up in
this kind of sense and then i don't know
maybe expand the koala franchise in the
future if necessary but
not in here yeah no totally i agree
yeah oh my god still really cool i love
this hotel i love this
vibe of it and i love the fact that it
is so different from the other one
it kind of really plays a good role in
this balance between this this
hyper um hyper luxury
stuff on the other side and this more
like family oriented
um very much going into i think it goes
really good in line with the
style of most of the buildings in the
quality resort so really cool
i love it definitely yeah i i can
understand where your
um kind of disappointment is
because you know it doesn't look
significantly different but
it it is i mean we we knew what we were
uh that the inside of that building
wasn't done
um it was just kind of open space
because you could kind of see it through
the windows
it it changes so much when you can see
like stuff
through the glass oh yeah it just looks
so much better
wow i'm glad you guys like it it's
awesome dear of course
yeah so it's finally time to do some fun
stuff again soon and start
you know building new things but i'm
glad that you're seeing has an interior
because i also feel like
everything in kuala luzu at the end has
to fit together and be as complete as
possible
and this building was just kind of uh i
don't know
a little bit of a an issue with that
but yeah yeah i would say get a computer
would be your first
thing to do and then you can have fun
you can you can have the fun that we're
having with
yeah we can zoom in so hard into it
right now and i can't wait to get my
hands on a 30x
all right out of anybody
oh yeah god if i can get one honestly
but i you will be fine you will find i
think i'm gonna stock up soon
i mean that's i think they could have
expected that so
yeah yeah not for sure
so what's the plan for uh the next
kawaii episode
i think it's me again right rudy yep
yeah all right yeah
i got a plan there's not much space left
so i think this time we can straight
away say that i'm going to make the
connection between the education center
and the koala habitat that lady did
lastly
i have a certain plan what i put there
um and i'm gonna see how much time i
have but maybe i'm also going to start
with the uh
connection of the water element what we
still need to do mike you know what's
coming from the highlands
yeah so maybe i'm gonna tackle that
already so that the bengal tigers
finally get some fresh water
the thing is y'all started adding stuff
there and they're like oh just just
connect the waters like oh okay
let me just put my magic wand out there
oh yeah no i i think i have an idea how
to incorporate that in the build so
uh we're gonna try that so that we have
that out of the way because if i gonna
you know if i would go in and just
you know cram something in there even
more i don't know how you would be able
to
build a water element in any way so um
no i'm gonna take care of that okay good
okay
sounds good all right cool well then uh
thank you everybody for uh for watching
this video i know it's been
quite a mess and maybe not my usual kind
of stuff
but it's uh it's been pretty important
to the to
to me at least and i'm really happy with
the result
and uh thank you rudy and mike for
stopping by
at last thanks for having us oh i'm so
glad it's finally done after so many
tries of getting this episode together
i really hope everyone out there
appreciates that because it was gonna
say don't say that yeah you haven't
you haven't rendered it and uploaded it
yet oh god okay yeah
crossing my fingers well we're almost
there
we're almost there anyway we'll see each
other next week or maybe sometime later
we'll see each other at some point in
time
on rudy's channel maybe it will be next
week maybe not
yeah depending alright bye guys